let's take a look at sam henches he's
going to be the northeast ohio ford
dealers indian starting pitcher tonight
henches this will be his 11th start he
did make one other start against the
angels that came on may 17th it was only
for an inning and two thirds he gave up
five hits six runs gave up a home run to
ohtani he walked three only had one
strikeout so he's going to have to do
better than what he did in his last
start shohei ohtani digs it
roller to the right side bobbled there
but jimenez
on to first in time man a four pitch
walk to fletcher and that will bring up
phil gosling
good breaking ball and that was a beauty
that's what he needs to do right there
jared walsh this is the guy that made
albert pujols expendable there
you change takes it himself and the
inning is over no runs no hits one left
the indians are coming to bed i mean
brielle on the mound two and one with a
four seven one fourth he'll be his fifth
start now of the season for jaime berea
throwing the ball very very well
especially his fastball velocity so
straws aboard and he's always the threat
to run here's amanda rosario and a
broken back signal in the left field
sends miles straw to second
and back to back singles to start it off
tonight
runners at first and second with one out
and here's
fran mill reyes here's the pitch a swing
in the drive to deep left center away
back go on
so friend el reyes
with a joyous dance around the bases
a three-run missile to the bleachers and
left-center better now
breaking ball and a swing and a miss but
the indians have struck three-run homer
france
here is brandon marsh swing and a miss
what an inning for sam hinches they go
one two three
punctuated with a strikeout two down
miles straw the batter he's singled and
scored in the first runner goes 3-2
pitch hit down the line is it fair it is
a fair ball into the corner off and
running two you change around third he's
gonna score easily and in the second
with a two out rbi double is miles straw
and it's four to nothing cleveland
and ahmed rosario sucks one up the alley
that'll go to the wall
straw will score
amen into second
back to back two out rbi doubles for the
indians and they lead it five to nothing
cece tell the truth he is the biggest
fan of this guy in the world
since april he's been yelling this is
his favorite player guys since i got a
chance to see him uh live in 2019 i've
been telling everybody he's the best
player i've ever seen in my life
lines that one
in a right field picked up by zimmer
holding third is suzuki from tony at
first suzuki at third and here comes
fletcher with one out
fletch
in the right field
and that scores suzuki ohtani stops at
second base and phil gosselin will be
the batter the next delivery
swung on banged up the middle near
second grabbed by the second baseman
ximena steps throws double play heading
over three straight two out singles have
loaded up the bases for the nine hole
hitter the second baseman andres jimenez
[Music]
and he pops it into left field adele
has it and that is a big big out it
keeps it at 5-1 indians leave him loaded
and we're headed to the fourth count
on iglesias who lined to short his first
time up center field miles straw with
that great diving catch oh what a play
by miles straw diving headlong toward
the infield and he grabbed that sinking
liner just before it hit the grass so
stefan will go to work on brandon marsh
swung on line drive caught by the second
baseman jimenez
he leaped in the air to do it not too
high but got up there just the same to
make a nice sleeping catch the year it
has been for ohtani and tom mentioned
earlier he's had great success in his
career against the tribe with seven home
runs and 14 driven in in 14 games swing
and a miss he struck him out with a low
fast
and the inning is over
we'll count to zimmer
oh he kid got the call that was maybe a
baseball and a half out
ramos swings
misses and jose martin is really
settling in now to his major debut
tonight is going uh quite well right now
here's daniel johnson
and he got him how about that i think
it's a marty parte
punching out the sides
out of the bullpen his debut strikes out
the side
chang the first baseman here's the 2-2
that is a called third strike
fastball at the knees gets chang he is
out looking with one away in the bottom
of the six the nine hole hitter andres
jimenez will be the next batter
and it's swinging a miss there
that's a nasty slip of garrett the man
with a three run bomb tonight to left
center steps to the plate fran mill
reyes bases loaded two down five to one
indians
smash left field base hit
miles scores here comes amid
it's a two out two run single for the
franimal
and the indians tack on two more and
lead it seven to one
so the indians now have bradley zimmer
at the plate two out two on broken back
flare to left it falls and coming around
to score is jose
it's all going the indians way now jose
iglesias has lined out twice and nothing
to show for it he sends another liner to
center that goes straw over the shoulder
basket
not basket catch but an over the
shoulder type catch
that
he makes looks so routine he is
some kind of slick in center field two
down here's another kit one of the best
prospects in baseball brandon marsh 2-2
and missed and trevor stefan finishes
with a strikeout three scoreless innings
for the indians right-hander now rosario
who has two hits a walk and a
two-for-three night
iglesias
got the out there
and the seventh inning
is over
here's otani stepping up he's had one of
the
four hits that the angels have had in
the game
that one chang kicks
and can't retrieve rotani gets down the
line obviously very very quickly so a
man aboard with two down for david
fletcher
shoots it what a play by you
an error on one at bat and on the next
play
a dynamite defensive gem to end the
inning
full count
on jose ramirez
there's a drive to deep left field that
one is not coming back jose ramirez home
run number 28. he passes said the alabar
junior on the indians all-time hit list
jose
sold for three
he's gonna try right field bradley
zimmer is there
book it
the indians hammer the angels in the
series opener by a final score of nine
to one